we've talked some about the meaning of
the cards but now I want to show you how
they use for fortune-telling I'm going
to shuffle the deck and then I'm going
to lay them out in one of the most
common patterns the Celtic cross
normally we would be doing a reading for
a specific person in this case I don't
have someone to do a reading for so I'm
just going to talk about what the cards
would mean in different positions the
first card is intended to represent the
person who is asking the question the
current this card is laid in the center
upright or reversed however it's drawn
from the deck and then another card is
played across that this card represents
the problems that the person is facing
in this case our first card was the
three of swords which you can tell it's
somewhat a bleak card to begin with and
then it's been crossed with the tower
and the tower as we mentioned before
it's quite a difficult card you can see
that it's a bit of chaos either upright
or reversed to the left of these cards
we place one that represents the past of
the person in question and to the right
we place a card that represents their
future above we place a card that
represents the conscious goals of our
current below we place one that
represents their subconscious goals you
can see a lot of duality here the self
and the conflict the before and the
after the conscious and the subconscious
after that four cards are stacked from
bottom to top on the right hand side the
first one represents advice that should
be given to the current the second one
is about external influences which could
be positive or negative
card number nine second-to-last
represents the hopes and fears of the
current this is one card where it's
especially important to look at both the
regular meaning and the reversed
meanings finally our last card card
number ten is about the outcome that is
likely to occur this outcome card can
also be read both reversed and upright
you can think of it as if you take the
advice this will happen if you don't
take the advice that will happen this
requires a lot of work between the
fortune teller and the current you need
to understand the meaning of the cards
but you also need to understand where
that person is when they're asking the
question you can't just do a reading
blank for someone you need to know a
little bit about them so that's one of
the most important things to know about
all of this
you can't automatically generate this
just because someone takes the advice
that was prescribed for them doesn't
mean that they are going to be free with
their money or that they're going to be
covetous of it you need to understand
where that person is in their life and
what the appropriate advice to give is
based on that card you can't just read
it straight and hope that it works
this is common across a lot of
fortune-telling systems including Aoife
in the Yoruba tradition you really need
a connection with a human being so this
is the Celtic Cross it's not the only
spread that you'll see people will
arrange cards in different ways
especially with different decks but it
is the most common and if you go to a
fortune-teller you might see them use
this spread